Al Gore did not invent the internet but
he did invent the phrase information
superhighway and what better metaphor to
help explain this idea of the
controversial notion of net neutrality
so let's use a superhighway metaphor
let's take a drive arrive a bandwidth
hog and gas-guzzling beats like Steve
McQueen's 1968 Mustang GT and pullet a
metaphor for a video we pull out of the
hooli parking lot we hit the interstate
the backbone of the internet at full
speed as fast as a hundred gigabits of
seconds the backbones are owned by a
handful of companies private companies
like AT&T Deutsche Telekom level-3
CenturyLink
and all of our fellow travelers are
traveling the same fast speed and total
reach the exit that last mile is owned
by a small group of Internet service
providers like Comcast Time Warner Cable
and Verizon they have different rules of
the road we may have gotten off the
information superhighway had a blazing
fast speed now we're hitting traffic but
while the traffic jams some of our
fellow travelers others like say the
Netflix 18-wheeler monster-truck well
they were able to pay for their own fast
life that's exactly the kind of deal
that Netflix struck recently the Comcast
allowing their service to get to
consumers faster than their competitors
is that fair well net neutrality rules
would make it an even playing field for
all the drivers on our road in that last
mile the toll keepers of course like
Comcast and Time Warner Cable well they
don't like this they want to have their
own rules for the road but drivers like
us we just want to enjoy the freedom of
the open road